NARRATOR: The Sahara hasn't
always been a desert.
At one time it was a savanna.
Now I could cite a bunch of
statistics about rainfall,
but just look at this
satellite photo of Africa.
That's all sand and rock.
But 7,000 years ago it was
a very different story.
There are cave drawings
from that period featuring
cows and elephants.
It was a grassland.
But those pictures
of cows eventually
gave way to pictures of camels.
The weather changed, the
rain slowed and then stopped,
and the desert took over.
We know about the
Sahara's ancient history
because of those small,
scattered cave paintings.
But for more recent
history, for the story
of man's place in the desert,
we have towns like this one--
though we may not
have it for very long.
Michael Huniewicz was planning
a trip through Mauritania,
through the thick of the Sahara
desert, when he found something
worth checking out.
MICHAEL HUNIEWICZ: Went
to my local library
looking for a guidebook
on Mauritania,
which they didn't have.
But they had one on West Africa,
and it had maybe two pages
dedicated to Mauritania.
And there it was, "The Forgotten
Libraries of the Sahara."
What can possibly sound
more romantic than that?
NARRATOR: The
guidebook was talking
about this town, Chinguetti,
and the forgotten libraries
there, which are
a local treasure.
Back in the 13th
century, the town
was a major stop for caravans
hauling wool, barley, dates,
ivory, ostrich feathers,
gold, and slaves
along the well-worn trade route.
And apparently there are
written records of this.
MICHAEL HUNIEWICZ: They
describe the caravans
coming in and out
of the city back
in the day, some of the
mentioning tens of thousands
of camels daily.
NARRATOR: Those records
are just one part
of the forgotten libraries,
because as all the goods passed
through Chinguetti over the
centuries, as did knowledge,
scholars here collected books
on math, language, astronomy,
and law.
A mosque was built, and some
of the earliest Koranic texts
found their way to
these libraries.
Chinguetti quickly became
known far and wide as an oasis
and learning in a vast
and hostile desert.
But eight centuries
later, Michael
arrived to find a
very different place.
Chinguetti feels
like a ghost town,
and it's really hard to
believe that supposedly
4,000 people live there.
I'm not sure what they do.
Some of them work
in the libraries.
in the local schools
for children called "madrasa."
NARRATOR: The
libraries are now what
put Chinguetti on most maps.
And they've earned it a place on
UNESCO's list of World Heritage
Sites.
Day to day, though, it's up to
the small army of librarians
to protect the books and share
their knowledge with visitors.
MICHAEL HUNIEWICZ:
There are librarians
who are kind enough to show
you the books, many of which
are centuries old.
The librarians handle
the books using gloves.
But you get the impression
that it's not the safest way,
and indeed many of the books
are literally falling apart.
NARRATOR: And sadly, that
might be an apt metaphor
for Chinguetti itself.
The librarians do their
best to keep the town going,
but they get little help from
the Mauritanian government,
which has its hands full
dealing with Al Qaeda factions
within its borders.
And most importantly, they must
fight the desert which is ever
encroaching on the town.
Michael left Chinguetti with a
sense of impermanence weighting
on him.
MICHAEL HUNIEWICZ: No one knows
how much longer than libraries
will stand, as the
population is dwindling,
the state of the books
is deteriorating,
and the sand is slowly
taking over the town.
NARRATOR: As cities
continue to grow,
small villages and
towns like Chinguetti
are disappearing
at a rapid rate,
alongside the last
nomadic tribes who
lived in these spaces.
Watch this episode
to find out more.
Photographers have
been taking pictures
of disappearing cultures since
the early 1900s, when Edward S.
Curtis started documenting
some American Indian tribes
before their traditional way
of life disappeared completely.
Thanks for watching.
And don't forget to
subscribe to Seeker Stories.